all i'm saying to you
is that jimmy he knew
without any words that i got what he was
doing
i'm starting to make clothes for him
he's freaking out he loves it
but what does jimmy always want more
money mean nothing to him he didn't even
know what you're talking about never
heard of money
mean nothing you know it's past money
way past money so you guys never
discussed money never
not once never are you kidding me no he
would just say
go to them and get the check or you know
whatever how did you
figure out how much to charge him ah now
you're into tony ackerman
so tony
in the early days we would come up with
a price here's
you know crushed velvet pants they
didn't have
crushed velvet in those days so we crush
it ourselves and we're doing fabric
covered buttons and he's wearing these
pants at woodstock
okay aqua front seam pants so the pants
are tight to the knee
and then if you look from the side that
it's coming down like this then it gets
wider as it comes to your foot so it's
going out to the toe of your shoe
and then to your heel he
sees what we're doing he just wants more
um he's he knows these people
he knows tony he knows michael
they're just about making clothes that
are cool that's the there's no
thing you know i don't need you know
whatever
autographs or mean nothing to me and
jimmy
just as an aside says to my little
italian business partner this is maybe
1968 or 9. talking about tony
talking about tony women are having sex
with me
just to say they had sex with jimi
hendrix meaning i wasn't in the room
when he told her this story
he's talking to her because he can talk
to her as a human
and he's getting something off his chest
which is a hurt
and he says to her women are having sex
with me just to ha say they
had sex with jimi hendrix i'm 26
and a [ __ ] so my reaction is well
if there's a problem me and the boys can
help fill in the blanks we don't want
anyone's feelings to be hurt
meaning it's just stupidity
then i figured it out afterwards in the
years that went by
and women's libs started to happen that
this is insulting to jimmy very
insulting
meaning they just want a piece of him
they were stealing the clothes
when he says to me in this letter dear
couple
i need close expresso send whatever you
have immediately and i'm thinking
dude who the hell you think you're
talking to this is mike i'm
i just sent you a whole wardrobe
you know what the hell's wrong with you
then
mike figures out what's going on what's
going on is that the girls
are stealing the clothes that's number
one number two
he's splitting the clothes i'm using
silk and rayon rayon
velvet that i'm talking about meaning
this is rayon velvet
so rayon rayon how do you spell that
all right oh and okay you're asking the
wrong person about spelling anything
but that that one i knew that's nice yes
yes yes
so rayon velvet
when it i'm making tight pants for
a rock and roll guy who
drops his ass down to the ground holding
the guitar in front of him
this rayon velvet this is meant for a
proper ladies gown
and a story this is not rock and roll
there's nothing rock and roll
and but now we're back to the thing
about that we were talking about
knowing the specifications of all these
different fabrics
so rayon
different colors run different ways
that's number one
from perspiration from washing
you know you get you give someone a
rayon shirt that's red
you know and it's a drummer his body's
going to be red at the end of the
this one's not rayon that's cotton
um anyway all i'm saying to you is that
rayon
at the end of its as you start to
stretch it
to its the end of its life it'll just
split it'll just split you'll have a
foot long split in the thing
he was splitting the pants i never knew
this he never says it
to me ever he just says in a letter try
to double stitch the pants
right that's what he's saying right now
just as an again an aside
maybe four or five years after jimmy
dies
robin trower who we're making clothes
for really known guitar player
is playing in lakeland i go there this
is a
proper english guy not into drugs
you know whatever um very proper
and cool we go there
he plays we delivered some clothes
anyway he now
he and i and a couple of the roadies
go out for dinner after the gig
one of the guys is a guy named jerry
stickles
this is jimmy's roadie from the
beginning
the beginning and what i'm saying to you
about rhodey is that
this guy will do whatever it takes to
save whatever the situation is that's
going on
with whoever he's working for this is
the no fool around kind of thing this is
not just someone
setting up the microphones this is his
whole life is devoted to
let's save jimmy who just got in a car
accident
or did this or got caught with that you
know whatever the thing is
he's the parachute when [ __ ] goes wrong
okay that's a way of saying it
parachute says it all so
jerry's there with us and he says
that or he tells this story that
jimmy um
[Music]
i forgot where i was wait a second
you you are meeting them at dinner or
something yeah
yeah so jerry stickles is there and he
tells his story
that jimmy is playing gig in seattle
that's his home
it's a revolving stage
jimmy drops his ass down to the ground
with his guitar in front of him splits
the pants
they throw him an english
union jack flag okay
he ties it on him like a diaper
two knots on his hip it's the way i
understand it i never saw a picture of
it
and the gig goes on all i'm saying to
you is that that's why
jimmy's saying to me try to double
stitch the pants
you know as the years went on i learned
well you can't use this fabric on that
human being because he can split it
he doesn't wear underwear right that's
the that's the legend
no underwear baby no underwear oh jesus
could you imagine
can you see that happen can you imagine
so